well as we have been reporting since 11
o'clock last night Confederate symbols
including UNL B's mascot hey Reb have
been and are being removed all across
the country as a result of calls to end
the systemic racism
Kirsten Joyce joining us now with
reaction from the director of
african-american studies at UNLV
Kirsten Denise we caught up with UNLV
assistant professor Javon Johnson who
says what are the important things to
remember is the ways in which young
activists have pushed a needle in this
country in terms of conversations
Johnson adds that we think a lot about
lawmaking in policy but don't always
talk enough about the work on the ground
that people are doing the work that is
forcing lawmakers to have conversations
about change and reform he says what's
happening now represents a turn in
history the lone robust history and the
amount of people who have fought against
this and what must be said here is that
this moment whatever happens in this
moment was made possible because of
those moments before it is one thing to
remove a statue it is another thing to
remove the laws the policies the rules
that govern and maintain racism as a
practice in this country and in that
that's gonna be a long fight in that
that that is also the beginning that is
also a part of this right that this is
only one part and then I'll be it a
small bit necessary part as for UNLV
mascot Johnson says dating back to the
1970s African American and Native
American students were some of the first
groups to push to remove Beauregard and
the rebel name which at that time they
said had clear Confederate ties he says
it's important to note the
administration listen this time whereas
they didn't in the past